peter has tallied every single visual
effects shot in spider-man to say the
least i am shook how many shots are
there 153
peter sent over a rough cut today of his
spider-man cake day short film there's a
lot of stuff that's great about it but
it's only about half done and you are
hoping to have this done 15 days from
now
that is the maximum number of days i
have you have to finish 10 shots per day
every day for the next two weeks let's
say you're working 10 hour days you have
to take an hour or less per shot every
day for the next two weeks
[Music]
hey what's up see mike hey man what's
the most about the effects you ever had
in one of your first films uh i did a
smash bros video back in the day the
project took me a year there's probably
50 or 60 or 70 full cgi green screens
everything uh it was it was intense it's
like 120 100 110 120 amp drink like 122.
how did it take you to do that like a
month and a half or my friend helped me
yeah it was crazy it's important to note
that not all vfx shots are created equal
peter has 153 a solid chunk of them are
labeled full cgi and apart from like
laying out the groundwork he does not
have a single completed shot
what
two weeks how long does he have
15 days 15 sorry bud
okay but but okay here's the flip side
if i actually do do it how cool would
that be
that'd be it'd be legendary either way
this video is going to be incredible
it's just are you being realistic with
yourself about how long this is going to
take i am already cutting out shots i
got one shot cut out so far 152 shots
all right
today we're here with portal a and
google the idea is to take a small scale
zootrope which is essentially just a
spinning collage of either 3d models or
different frames of an image that make
up a moving image you're spinning this
collage and you get to see the final
effect we want to take that and we want
to do that on a big scale with people
instead of just an animation looping we
want to continue the action and tell a
story over a minute and a half to two
minutes this is the first time anyone
has ever done this at least on the
internet kind of like a chaplain i used
chaplin as like an example i think we
were trying to go too much for like
what's the artsy story about it as
opposed to like how do we entertain in
the best way possible you know kind of
looking at a lot of old chaplain stuff
there's not like this big story it's
just he needs money trying to do xyz and
it's he's trying to get there in
different different funny ways because
it's not working out for him that's the
vibe here he's going but everyone is
doing the same thing in the zotrope as
he goes to do something it's happening
behind him too so he's like stealing
from himself but he doesn't realize it
as he starts to realize that he tries to
game the system that still doesn't work
and then he realizes the only way for
this to work is for everyone to come
together to form into the same person so
we're going out we're shooting a
technical test for this zootrope idea
we're shooting it as if this is for real
so we're bringing out all the equipment
thrown into the computer and see if we
can get one of the people on this
merry-go-round to sync up in the front
of frame what fairways would like to
test 6 12 18 24 1.
so how many people are going to have
six people that's the goal is to have
six people 10 feet 13.3 seconds yeah
basically the point is to figure out
what frame rate you need for uh each
person to sync up in the same spot from
there it's just hopefully it's syncing
up in front of the camera not like off
to the side we did a test on a
merry-go-round in a playground we have
to have this merry-go-round spinning
consistently at an even rate for us to
be able to speed up the video and just
have it work so we want to get divided
divide it right yeah so one divided by
0.3 this is a little tiny little frame
rate thirty point zero two three point
zero two frames per second we did that
test it actually worked as janky as it
was it worked and then we got a decent
effect from it so i was like i don't
know if the the wheel is also gonna be
built with
here we go hitting one g
see if we get uh that's clearly 2g
yeah we just hit 3g
oh
i think we're in really good shape i
think we're really set up for success
right now because the actual version
will have a motor to be completely
consistent hopefully at least we'll have
professional dancers so the goal today
is to get all six dancers on that
merry-go-round with 12-second revolution
time so every time it spins once that's
12 seconds these guys have put together
essentially a display rig for a car you
know like you'll see a car sitting on
the side of the car show it'll be
spinning that's what we're working with
they have kind of crafted it into a
merry-go-round you know with all the
poles and the bars and stuff and they
can control how fast it goes we got six
people on this merry-go-round it takes
12 seconds to complete one spin one
revolution wren helped me do the math
yesterday it's gonna take um an hour and
a half to get a minute and a half the
idea is that when these guys are
spinning around the front is right the
back is dark naturally they're gonna be
silhouetting the person in front we have
to break up the hour and a half long
take into sections that way the dancers
don't pass away and turn into crispy
tombstones yesterday i shot the final
choreography it was a minute and a half
long i slowed that choreography down by
the same amount i would be speeding up
our footage today we have this hour and
20 minute take to use as reference today
and everyone's gonna be going off of
that i'm gonna be going off of that for
camera because i worked in camera motion
into the test d ran the dance guide he's
gonna be off camera doing the moves that
i was doing in the reference video i
shot yesterday but the slo-mo version
the tai chi version right that way all
the dancers can reference him i'll be
referencing that same video for camera
motion we're gonna have to figure out
the camera timing how fast do we need to
be moving this camera how slow do we
need to be moving this camera to match
the camera moves that i put into the
reference video
we're almost at the cut point guys
[Music]
yeah guys hop in the shade catch your
breath we can unzip your masks we'll
take a little break
it looks amazing it's like watching a
meditation video
the music is so helpful
we just shot
206 gigs filled up half of a 512 gig
card in one take that was half this card
yeah
all right
how's it going guys it's been a while
it's been about one scene but about a
week of uh real time let me tell you i'm
feeling pretty burnt out i've been
pulling a lot of 10 hour days all i do
is this every day doing vfx non-stop
basically and let me tell you
i'm kind of sick of it but
let me i'll show you what i've done so
far i've actually been working on
completing and putting shots into the
edit this week and so you can see this
page has all the shots i've completed
then if i continue scrolling
you can see all of this
that hasn't even been touched yet so
i've completely taken out 25 shots or so
from the edit i sat down with sam and
nico and they suggested a lot of shots
that
while they might have been cool weren't
necessarily needed to make the final
piece cohesive so far i've completed
about 25 shots and i have a couple more
shots that are just waiting to render
making progress but slow progress the
question becomes now am i still gonna be
able to finish this by the time i go
back up to san francisco and the answer
is i have no idea
hopefully i have about let's count up
the days seven eight nine ten days 10
days left to do roughly 100 shots which
is 10 shots a day thankfully i did three
visualizations for them which means i
basically have animated them already i
just haven't put in all the city assets
or made them look pretty or anything
like that so if i really keep my head
down and keep working i might spend a
few nights here at the studio so i can
just save time driving to and from work
might be able to finish it i really hope
so
if you would like to donate pizzas to
peter my venmo's
home studio this is exactly what a
picture should look like when you look
up what a recording studio should not
look like google what not to do for home
recording uh this should pop up yeah we
have the the drum set miced up two
overheads uh one kick one snare one mono
room running into a completely separate
system for drums then we are for
everything else not ideal
but it'll get the job done
[Music]
[Music]
clint was like
hey sam
i got an idea you know that zojo video
let's score it ourselves and i was like
i'll be over in one minute let me hop in
my car i'm driving now
[Music]
and then uh i crashed my car on the way
over here
[Music]
anyway so yeah we're here trying to
figure this out they put the drum set
down here we got microphones casey's got
two computers i i am a one-man band i
work out of one machine i have one
preamp
that is mono we have to record a drum
set here with several microphones so i
pulled out an old computer but it's
going to get the sound i love i love
seeing you talk to the camera
because i don't look at it directly
don't look at it
i'm very aware of that our productivity
dropped by like
89
as soon as the camera showed up we were
jamming for like we got all the stuff
figured out as soon as so karma as soon
as you get here the productivity goes
down by ninety percent i need to start
playing happy birthday freaking
[Music]
so
let's just start with your clickity
clacks okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]